[Music]
Allah there's only one word and muham is
his messenger
Allah
Allah there's only one God and Jesus was
his messenger
[Music]
Allah I don't know why I did that maybe
maybe it's just to break
alhamdulillah which is a greeting of
peace peace be unto you and this is a
greeting of all the messengers of God
this is something that started from the
beginning from the first man
Adam to Moses to Noah to Jesus and the
last and final messenger sent to mankind
the prophet Muhammad peace be upon them
all they taught us to wish that greeting
of peace and that's what we're starting
with am alaykum alikum Asam what was
your name again njan Baron tell us a
little about yourself well I'm an
American Muslim I'm 11 years old I go to
a laar school in
Tam
[Applause]
alhamdulillah so tell us now you're how
old I'm 11 years old and you said you're
an American Muslim yes what does that
mean to you to be an American Muslim
well I'm very proud to be an American
Muslim it means a lot to me to in the
essay um usually when you're doing a
report you go into books and the
internet but during this essay when you
have to talk about what it means to you
I just looked into my art I didn't look
in a book or
[Applause]
anything okay tell us uh about yourself
I'm 13 years old I go to Sal in um Fort
Lauderdale and um I'm in eighth
grade American Muslim how you you're
born in America
yes do you worship a moon God what do
you worship a moon God a moon God no no
who who is
Allah Allah is the creator of the
universe okay good M how do you feel
being an American Muslim I feel
proud tell us do you know anything about
Jesus yes do you what do you know about
Jesus Jesus is Prophet Esa and he's a
prophet of Allah he came to spread the
message of Islam but over time people
changed the real message and translated
into English but they didn't translate
it correctly do you love Jesus yes we do
love Jesus as a mighty messenger of God
that's beautiful see cuz some people
might think Muslims are the Antichrist
they don't like Jesus they don't like
you know our way of life congratulations
Mar you guys are a good rep
representation of American Muslims doing
good keep up the good work
alhamdulillah it's not the spin Factor
just the in the dean show here so before
we have you on the podium addressing the
audience I want to ask you a few
questions absolutely tell us now how did
you you you shared a a a a a beginning
with me how you started it was really
interesting can you share this how you
got started with this whole organization
sure in 2008 there was a DVD that was
distributed um it was called
Obsession and uh I was at work I
remember where I was and I I got the DVD
and you know radical uh Islam something
radical Islam war against the west or
something like that so I saw it I took
it home and I watched
it and it really it hit me and uh I
realized then that this is the path that
you know I need to take
because um when I
see Muslims being attacked when I see
these hard things it hurts so uh at that
moment is when I turn my life um
inshallah to serve Allah subhana wa
taala and uh make a difference for the
community inshah tell us how do you feel
I know myself just like yourself when I
started to see these these things the
misrepresentation out there and I
started to study and what I was studying
I was like this is not Islam this is not
my way of life this is not my religion
and I got to sit with some of the most
prominent Scholars here in America and
overseas and they came on The Dean show
and they condemn such actions as 9/11
shoe bom bomber underwear bomber all
these different bombers and whatnot you
know totally condemned it said this is
not a part of Islam consensus of the
Muslim Scholars
99.9% and now you hear people such as
this uh Alan West has not fully
explained explained his position Council
on American Islamic relations says it
received a one-word response from West
after asking him to disassociate himself
with people it considers anti-islamic
when when you hear someone like him come
on we have over here the consensus of
Scholars saying one thing
99.9% telling us what Islam is telling
us how we should live it and all the
good that it promotes but then you hear
someone like this coming on Muhammad
enacted the Hijra and he left and he
went out to Medina and stepping up like
he's a scholar stepping up and telling
us what our religion is teaching us how
does that make you feel the the the as I
said in the video earlier the the
majority of of the problem right now um
is people really don't understand Islam
for for us Muslims you know we're
dealing with Muslims every day so it's
normal for us but the majority of
Americans don't know any Muslims so
individuals like Alan and West um are
very dangerous because they project
themselves as self-proclaimed Scholars
um and people listen to them and they
understand them so this this is
dangerous for our community um you know
we're a very small community uh but we
have power um so you know this is uh a
problem and this is something that you
know we're pushing back that care pushes
back um all the time and that's our job
so anwers your question we as Muslims
once who have submitted to the one Crea
T the same God that Jesus worshiped the
same God that Moses Abraham all the
messengers of God they taught the same
way of life submit your entire self to
the one who created you that's what a
Muslim is so we as Muslims we follow
Islam submission to the one God now tell
us tell us please you know before you
get up I'm just itching I have so so
many questions the the other one that
that that comes to my mind have you had
a chance to reach out to him to invite
him for some pizza some Biryani maybe
soften his heart because all of the not
yet Muslims there are brothers in
humanity there are brothers in humanity
is it true have you had a chance to and
would you be willing to sit with the man
talk with the man one-on-one the teddy
bear that you are yeah absolutely a lot
of people think uh that I haven't tried
to engage Alan West um and I've tried
professionally with respectfully to
engage him without the media being
involved and uh just to have that
conversation to explain to him the
larger context of the verses that he
takes out of the Quran and does his
little sound bites so I I have tried uh
to engage with him um however he's uh
you know held suit and uh completely
streamlined however uh I got some good
news brother where's Dr basson there he
is over there um he just attended a
event in boa Ron it was an Interfaith
event and uh Professor Al HBY had some
success so inshah you know I'm going to
make Dua that brother Bassam can get
through to this individual um and uh
explain what Islam is and hopefully
these childish things can stop just just
a couple more please you got a little
emotional yeah in one of the videos
something was penetrating the heart what
happened it was the kids when
uh when when uh when I see kids you did
that on
purpose when I see kids being attacked
um and and there's issue with kids it it
really hurts and you know they're
defenseless so don't do that again um
this from the heart people need to see
this is this is I mean we're human
beings we hurt we shed tears people
don't understand that so they need to
understand that before you utter
something that's hurtful that can really
put someone down don't kick a man when
he's down help him up and this is what
we're about so inshallah God willing
when the world sees this they can see
like those are human beings they bleed
like we bleed they cry like we cry let's
not hurt these people let's work
together we got to be in this world
together it's already tough as it is so
let's not hurt my our brothers in
humanity so I I really want the people
to to to feel this this is not something
fake yeah no it is um that that video
when I was addressing the school board
because we got quite a few complaints uh
you know regarding Muslim children and
and uh you know even Educators teachers
harassing the Muslim Students um so that
you know that hurt and it it took me
back a little bit so that's why I got a
little emotional um uh so you know that
that's what happened okay two more I'm
sorry I know we're coming it short but
okay you'll keep it short but see that's
why you got to come on the show I have
so much to ask you uh Osama Obama
Al-Qaeda Hamas all these other things
they try to throw some dirt at you make
it stick hoping that if they throw
enough something will stick and they'll
mess up your white suit so when you hear
these things what do you got to do are
you know are you promoting some radical
Islam or what do you have to do with
alqaeda hus I like humus I don't have
nothing to do with Hamas I don't know
what do you say when they do you have
any ilation with with Al-Qaeda or what's
the other Osama or Obama or we we have
to understand that the Muslim Community
in the United States is being uh
politically attacked our civil liberties
are being attacked um and Care is the
largest most effective organization in
the country so anyone that has any
common sense that wants to hurt the
Muslim Community they're going to attack
the head going to attack the biggest one
um and that's why care gets a lot of
this propaganda propaganda is not new it
was back uh centuries and centuries and
centuries you know even in the time of
the Prophet Muhammad even the prophets
before him um so that's all baseless
garbage I don't even waste my time with
that uh but understand that that's what
it is people are attacking they see care
they see the power they see the the
strength when we fight for the community
civil rights um and uh they can't take
it they can't stand it so they want to
they want to get that care so that's
what that's all about so this is phony
balone uh propaganda Absolut propaganda
okay one last one if he did accept we
hope we pray to the creator of the
heavens and earth that the Allan wesy
West he can come and sit he accepts the
invitation would you be having birani or
pizza uh that's a good question you know
I'm I'm a I'm an indie paky food lover
so you know it's going to be would you
let him pick uh yeah yeah okay so Alan
West you get this come sit with the
muslimani with the Muslims or pizza or
hamburgers your door is open the mush's
open come sit with the Muslims talk to
the Muslims learn from the
Muslims say me why have you become a
Muslim now I I give a very frivolous s
so I say I want to be on the side of the
Angels is a Gody he's the number one rap
artist in the world he sold over 60
million records worldwide 60 million he
was a young guy who had basically
everything that some of the youth would
think that life is all about he had
everything you can
imagine thank you very much for joining
us here thanks for having me inshallah
we can have you too in the F uh future
you're also from Chicago I am from
Chicago I have a few things to say about
Chicago Vis this audience talk to us
tell us about Chicago well you know
we're we're very proud of our community
in Chicago and we're very proud of our
Care Organization in Chicago and you
know Ahmed yourself and in fact we we
border arrogance when it comes to how
proud we are and I'm going to have to
tell him that he has an upand cominging
rival in the Miami Muslim Community this
is an impressive Community I'm very
impressed with this dinner and uh things
things are moving along in this
community alhamdulillah it's very
impressive and it's the work of nard and
when Nar is talking about the problems
uh that the Muslim Community faces we
have to keep in mind if your roof has a
leak in it you're going to fix it if
your car has a problem you're going to
fix it if your community has a problem
you need to fix it we cannot excuse
ourselves by saying that's not my roof
we cannot excuse ourselves by saying
that's not my car if you assume for a
moment that well the federal agents are
calling somebody else's children they're
calling them at the same mosque that
your children attend if you think to
yourself for a moment that the problems
plaguing some people or plaguing only
immigrants or plaguing somebody from
some Community or other we have to
remember Muslims live only Under One
Roof so when NAD is talking about these
things when he's talking about hiring a
lawyer for example this is a real thing
so tell us our dear beloved brother just
for those many of us know who you are
just for some of the people who don't
know tell us just in a couple sentence a
little bit about yourself uh well I'm a
professor at depal University in
religious studies with a focus on
Islamic Studies I was born in Baghdad
Iraq and uh like many of you came here
to the United States with my family and
I have a daughter who's 9 years old and
I've seen my daughter go the same things
that I went through when I was a kid
during the first Gulf War went through
the first Gulf War then we go through
9/11 then we go through the second Gulf
War and yet she's still being plagued by
the same things at school that I'm being
plagued that I was plagued by as a Young
Man growing up in the United States so
things haven't changed and in many ways
things have gotten worse I agree uh and
that's one of the reasons why I'm here
that's one of the reasons why care is so
important to me tell us now you saw the
video yes and you see some of this this
hate rhetoric how does that affect you
how does how do you feel when you see
this stuff well it's not about how it
affects me personally it's about how it
affects our country we this rhetoric uh
is not merely a rhetoric of hate it's a
rhetoric to displace productive energies
and to uh distract everyone from what's
really going on and when when I speak
here in a minute we I'll address some of
these things over the last 10 years our
economy has floundered we've wasted
billions and billions of dollars on Wars
that we never needed to fight those
billions enriched a few CEOs at a few
companies and everybody didn't notice
what was going on because they were so
busy focused on hating your beard or
hating your name or hating the way you
pray which of course is ridiculous
particularly in a country where
religious freedom is is
Paramount you think there's some of this
stuff going look over
there what's you see I took the money
you think some of this stuff is going
distraction absolutely absolutely you
think some of this stuff is going hey
look over there and you look and then
you your hands in the pocket you think
some of these things are just
distractions from the bigger events
focusing on this you know Hocus Pocus
stuff with the Muslims and then
distracting people from the bigger
issues the human beings from bigger
issues yes I do yeah so give us some
advice what do you feel now you know um
living in this country what could we do
as productive law-abiding citizens to
help make a change we need to remain
positive and most importantly we need to
be organized and being organized means
we do not expend energy arguing with one
another we don't expend energy looking
for the negative in each other the
Muslim Community cannot afford it this
community is under assault it's been
under assault for at least 10 years and
I would argue possibly 30 or 40 years
and we have to set aside our differences
whatever those differences may be those
are differences we can talk out amongst
each other but when it comes to public
speaking when it comes to issues facing
the community when it comes to what
position we take as a community we have
to remain United it's not a luxury that
we can afford to be disunited and to
consider our own personal beliefs our
own personal agendas uh by so doing
we're only limiting what we can
accomplish there's no record in history
that chose people forced by sword point
to convert to Islam when Islam spread
through countries they would set up
private churches and synagogues for the
non-muslims they were governing and
because of the good treatment they had
received they themselves would convert
if one considers the small number of
Muslims who initially spread Islam to
the West all the way from Spain and
Morocco into the east from India and
China One would realize that such a
small group of people could not force
others to be members of a religion
against their will it is also
interesting to note that when the
Mongols invaded and conquered large
portions of the Islamic empire instead
of destroying the religion they adopted
it one Islamic terrorism misconception
Muslims are
terrorists this is by far the biggest
misconception of Islam given unfairly by
stereotyping in the Public Image that
the media gives has anyone else noticed
how when a specific group of people
attack another group of people it is
labeled as a hate crime but when a
Muslim opens fire on anybody it is
quickly regarded as terrorism many
political dictators and officials or
extremist groups use the name of Islam
as a strategy to Garner followers and
attention when many of their practi is
go against the true basis of Islam the
media has also portrayed Islam as a cult
or a club where if you join you become a
terrorist and that is now part of your
agenda however all over the world people
practice Islam in the true form and use
it as a way of life there are many
verses in the Quan that go against the
idea of terrorism some of these verses
include fight the way of Allah those
that fight you but do not transgress
limits for God does not love
transgressors this basically means do
not fight except in self-defense and
even in doing so do not go beyond
defense another verse States if they
seek peace then you seek peace which
means do not attack people for no reason
or kill innocent people there is nowhere
in Islam whether it be in the Quran or
the teachings of Muhammad that promotes
the killing of innocent
people please subscribe to the dean show
follow us on our official Facebook and
Twitter pages in The Links below please
also help support the dean show by
making a donation in the link below